Welcome to "In Context", I am David
Pakman. The election begins officially
in just a bit over two weeks, but the
reality is that the election is now. The
early voting has started, the abscentee
voting has started, and we are seeing
the highest amount of early and abscentee
voting compared to any other election in
the history of the US, and in a bit I´ll
continue talking about that with you, but
first we will talk with deputy Debbie
Mucarsel Powell, representing the
district 26 of the State of
Florida. Well, first of all, What will happen with
the possible second finantial rescue
package because of the Coronavirus? There was already
a package, and for months there has been
the idea of a possible secondary package.
Will it happen? Will it no? When could
it happen? Maybe before the election, maybe in the
intermediary period after the 20 of
January? What do you expect? -Well, we
have been,
since May, trying to negotiate with the
Republicans in the Senate and with the
whole Administration, and unfortunately the
Senate turn it´s back upon thousands and thousands and
thousands of families here in the State of
la florida y en mi distrito y nosotros
Florida and in my District. We,
the President of the Chamber Nancy Pelosi
had been negotiating with the Secretary
of Treasury Mnuchin, they managed to
find an agreement in March when we
passed the CARE act, but what we
saw is that Mark Meadowsen, he is the
Chief of Staff of the
Trump Administration, and he has been
stopping any kind of negotiation.
The Republicans in this moment, David,
can´t agree on which type of
package they want to present to the Chamber.
We sent another package
a few weeks ago that includes that
payment, another direct payment to the
families of 1200 dollars, extends the
unemployment relief of 600 dollars
until January 2021. We are still in
the middle of a pandemic and I have been
talking with families here that are
really scared about
losing their homes, as they are unable to
pay rent.
entonces el paquete que nosotros estamos
So, the package we are currently
negotiating includes in our part that
assistance to paying rent, to
paying the mortgage of the families thatt
need that extra assistance, and also for
the people that own those places
in which live people that can´t
pay their rent. What the Republicans
want to do in this moment is
cutting taxes to big companies
and that is what´s included in the
package. That is why we are still
negotiating and is why I never lose my optimism,
David, that we are going to reach an agreement.
I have a lot of faith in how the
President of the Chamber was
also negotiating other packages,
including the one we passed in March, but
what we have to do is
pressure the Senate and tell them that
they NEED to help the families.
We are still in the middle of a pandemic, and the economic
recession will continue and will be worse
if we don´t send a proper economic relief
package in this moment of need to
so many families that need it, and for
small bussinesses also.- + This delay
is political, legal,
logistical? We saw this interview in CNN
last weekend with Nancy Pelosi
being interviewd by Wolf Blitzer, and it left me,
at least a bit, with the impression that
there is politial considerations from
both sides, and also other
considerations. What do you think? +
- We, if you see the dates in the
projects we´ve sent, we,
David, we started to work inmediately
in March to send assistance. We
passed a package in March knowing that it wouldn´t
be enough, because we
talked with every public health
experts. Inmediately we continued to
work to send another package to
the Senate in May. This is months prior to the
elections, we weren´t thinking
about what would happen in November, we
were thinking about what was
happening in this country today, and
we need a national strategy
so that we can controll the propagation of the Covid.
The Republicans and the Administration
showed us that they are
denying the danger that we have
in this moment due to another spike
(in the cases of Covid) in our country, and we are feeling
it here in the state of
Florida. So that has nothing to do with
politics, it is about the
necessities (of the people) and about what we
need in this moment, due to the
pandemic that we have in our
country. And unfortunately, there is no
national strategy, there is no courage
from the Republicans to admit that yes,
we must send another economic assistance (package) to
the families that need them. They want
to protect the biggest companies and their
bigger interests that are
00:05:09,400 --> 00:05:14,260
giving all the founding for their
campaigns, and maybe from this perspective
it is in fact politica. But this comes
to basically the values that
both parties represent. We
are fighting to get (Those packages)
for the families of the working class,
for the owners of small businesses.
The Republicans are trying to figure out
what they can pass to earn more political
points and protect their special
interests. - +Why is that the Coronavirus
is affecting more the latin/hispanic community?
_In which way_ is a part of the question,
but at the same time: Is it
because of financial reasons? Is it
because of particularities in the health of
the latin/hispanic population? A combination of
both? Something else? + - Well, there are
various reasons, and you are completely right,
David. Here in the state of Florida
we
are 25% of the entire population of the
state of Florida, but we are also
44% of all the cases of
Coronavirus in my district. And I
represent a District in which the majority
(of people) is Hispanic, almost 70% of the people
that lives in my district are Hispanic
people. And there are two reasons; basically
one of them is that we tend to have previous
conditions like diabetes or
hypertension, so the virus hits
us way harder in the mortality.
We
We are unfortunately way more prone to it.
But we are also the essential
workers of my district, and in the whole
country Hispanic people were the people
that never stopped working. They are the
people that have been working in
farms here South of the county
of Miami. The people that
are the nurses who constantly
have to take care of sick people in
the hospitals. They are the ones who drive
our public transport network, and they
haven´t had the necessary
protective gear. So we have to defend
the weakest communities, and now
we know, thanks to the cientifical data,
that the Hispanic community is one of the
most vulnerable communities to
Covid. That is why, in Congress,
I introduced a project that goes
towards these communities that have been
affected, to expand not only the
Covid tests, but also to have
the required infraestructure needed so that
when we have the aproved vaccines
they can get directly to the communities that
needs them the most, and that is the
hispanic community.-
+Exactly. You mentioned about the vaccines,
it is considered that when the vaccines are
ready, it will be first given to
medical workers in (dangerous) situations
in the hospitals,
and similar situations. After that,
the most plausible it would be to give it to the
most elderly people, and after that
we could start to think about the
economic considerations or else. What is being
done? What is being considered? That
could grow into a complicated situation from the
point of view about the availability of
the vaccines, and the economic context around
those that WANT a vaccine? + - Well, the
Congress, the hispanic Caucus of Congress,
we have talked about that a
few days ago with all the companies
of pharmaceutical equipment, not only national
but international as well, about how they
were planning in distributing the
vaccines to people and communities that
needs them the most, and without considering
the fact that they do or do not have the
money to pay for that
vaccine, and they told us something a bit
worrying, and this is why this elections are
so important:
They have signed a deal with the
government of the US, with the
administration of the White House, that
once they had the vaccine they will produce a
certain amount of vaccines, they give that to
the administration, and they (the administration)
decide how to distribute those vaccines. I
will say to you one thing, David. The Hispanic Caucus
is on high alert with what is
happening, and in this moment we
are working with the pharmaceuticals
and we will be on top of the
administration as long as
the administration of Donald Trump is still there.
to be asured that those vaccines
get to our communities.- + (That is) Very very
important, very important. We will make
a short pause, and we continue with Deputy
Debbie Mucarsel Powell from Florida. In
just a moment / We continue our conversation
with Deputy Debbie Mucarsel Poweel from
District 26 in the State of Florida.
Let´s talk a bit about misinformation and
about the fake news, (That are called fake
news in the US now)
with a lot of popularity, and  there is an
incredible amount of misinformation
and fake news specifically
targeted towards the hispanic voters
in the US, What is happening and why?+
- Ok, David, we discovered all the data
and evidence (that means that) Russia interfered
in the 2016 elections. I am part of
the judicial committee and in Congress we
had numerous audiences in which the FBI confirmed
that to us, and they gave us information that they
are seeing interferences once again. Which
I have seen here in southern Florida,
and Joaquín Castro in the State of Texas,
(We have seen that) those interferences are being
specifically
targeted towards Hispanic communities. We
have seen that there were a bit of
misinformation in social media, in the
chats like WhatsApp, close friends of mine
sent me articles that
were full of misinformation, but the
most worrying thing was when the mainstream
media, like the biggest newspaper
here in the South of Florida, the
Miami Herald, and also some certain radio
stations that were also including
that misinformation. So that is why we
asked the FBI to give us all
the information they are gathering, where
is it coming from and why is it targeting
these latin communities that are going
to be so important for the final
electoral vote in this November.
In fact, yesterday I received a letter from the FBI that
said that they are still investigating, as they do not have all
the information yet to give,
but Joaquín Castro and I
are looking at it to be asured
in where this is coming from,
but it is very interesting how it´s
specifically targeted towards the latin
community.-
+Yes, I am part of a group (In the US) of around
300 or 400 Argentinians in WhatsApp,
mostly educated people,
people with a lot of different
jobs and frequently
we share memes, video,s images, that are
related to the election, about fake
news and misinformation. Why is that
is is being so focused on targeting the hispanic
community? May it be because, with time,
the latin population is becoming
more important in the elections? +
-The latin community is extremely important,
right now we are representing the
largest ethnic group of voters in
the United States. In the latin community
our voice will be highly, not just
important but also powerful.
Right now we have the
responsability, the authority even, of
influencing how this election will end
in November.
00:12:50,710 --> 00:12:56,440
And, there are certain actors that understand
that very well, and are communicating it
in Spanish. You know, a lot of those
latin people that came into our contry, David, do
not have that kind of aliance with any party;
They are very independant, they want
to have all the information in front of
them before taking a decision, and that
is why they are doing it. If they do not
know where that information is
coming from, most think that it can be
true. A friend of mine,
from Colombia, that sent me articles that
are completely false, and when I
do a little of research
I found that they come from ultra-right.
an author from ultra-right-wing, and they are
repeating false things that we have
heard, maybe, from a web in Russia first
for example. This is something highly
dangerous, we have to protect the
electoral system of our country. We
can´t let nor Russia nor any other
external factor influences how we
are going to decide who is going to
govern the United States.-
+Incredible, incredible. Thank you so much,
we have been talking with Deputy
from District 26 from Florida, Debbie
Mucarsel Powell, it has been a pleasure
talking to you and we appreciate
incredibly your time.+ -Thank you-